I said I can still watch my children ski
and be skied directly into my back by
someone and then you continued
which is what happened exactly so you
were watching your children when you
allege that you were skied directly into
your back by someone my daughter was
down the hill my son was to my left so I
was skiing my eyes were not fixated only
on my son when Mr Sanderson skied
directly into my back
Oaks who's going to testify next week
said that your son Moses was saying
mommy mommy watched me
that's who you were watching right
that's Vegas the time there are right
right be right yes overruled go ahead
thank you
sorry what was the question when when
Moses is saying mommy mommy watched me
that's who you were looking at when you
were direct once when you were skied
directly into your back
I
do not recall Moses saying mommy mommy
watched me on the ski slope okay well
Apple was down further right yes she
didn't see it no okay and Moses he was
the one at least according to Carrie
Oaks was calling your attention
okay okay
um nine-year-old did he want more
attention to have somebody watch them
rather than 11
not necessarily okay Moses was skiing
above you though right he hadn't gotten
down as far as you he was on my left
and up
I was on the right he was oops sorry
he was on the left side of the slope
um yes I believe kind of a little bit
uphill okay and that's where your
attention was when you were hit
allegedly in the back I don't know where
my attention was the moment I was struck
in the back I'm sorry okay well that's
what you said which is what happened he
struck me in the back yes that's exactly
what happened okay I know but you said I
can still watch my children ski yes
meaning directly into my back by someone
which is what happened yes exactly
what's the pending question it sounds
like they're saying the exact same thing
what's the question the question is you
were watching your children ski when you
were struck in the back that's asked and
answered your honor overruled
I was skiing and looking downhill as you
do and I was skied directly into by Mr
Sanderson okay
on your left and
left into my recollection okay
all right and Carrie Oaks is the one who
says that he was the one calling your
attention you'll have to speak to miss
Oaks we will